did you write with these various actors
in mind or that come later yeah that
came much later I had I had some people
in in mind writing it and in a way like
I think that that would have been bad if
I would have got those actors because I
think that you you can only like it
becomes much more interesting then
because it you go from writing to
directing and then it's a completely
different set of like thinking and
analytical skills and you know I think
that the cast that I ended up with like
really helped create and write the story
with me in a way too because their
personalities I redid some rewrites when
after I cast for sure oh yeah before we
started shooting and the J and the James
lagrua the director I had just worked
with him as an actress and if we got
along like a house on fire he's amazing
and so I really wanted him to play that
part and he he's hilarious and wry and
like grumpy kind of in a way that is
like amazing and I was like I'm just
writing this character to like suit you
the most and you know luckily he he
ended up doing it but he was the only
one that I kind of really wrote it I did
think about Pamela for Cigna early on
too I was like there's no way we'll get
her oh the fact that we actually yeah
did is is pretty great so who was the
first actor that you presented the
script to and how did it go yeah I think
I mean dree was the first person that we
that we cast drew Hemingway who plays
Sweet Pea and that was obviously like
the most important character in the film
and you kind of had to figure things out
around whoever was going to be cast in
that role so I had seen starlet which is
this really great film that she did that
she carries in in so many ways
you know I was saying to earlier that I
didn't know after I saw starlit if she
was right for the role as I had written
it I didn't see it right away but I
loved her in that film and I liked also
like her her persona like outside of
being an actress she's kind of like this
I don't know like model I guess but she
has this connection with like young
girls and that's exactly who I wanted to
this film to kind of get to so she's
stuck in the back of my head and then
you know it's like just like a classic
like our casting director mentioned her
and she they sent her the script and she
called me yeah she called me and she
loved the script and she she read for it
and she was so natural and beautiful and
like committed and just very like
present which is really really hard to
do in an audition so I just knew she was
like an excellent actress that you know
that starlet wasn't a fluke and it
became really clear to me that like she
was exactly the right person for the
role because you know she is so natural
and subtle and she just has like so much
that's just happening in her eyes the
kind of actress that I really love and
the world around her is a bit I don't
want to say surreal but it's a little
bit off kilter and it's you know some of
the characters around her are a bit like
arch and so having someone who's really
grounded and like subtle for the
audience to identify with I think this
was the right choice and like it
couldn't have worked out better I think
she's so extraordinary and like rah and
the film just like honest she's just
very honest in the film right right and
she and as she is in starlet but you're
right it's two different composites of
totally different characters life
situation yes and yeah for sure
and in some of the smaller roles that
she's had in some bigger films like
she's often quite kind of like funny and
like you know goofy and I think that's
important for also a role like this
which is not like a funny role but you
want there to be a lightness to it cuz
it can't all be it takes you know
there's suicide in
in the in the film and but it can't all
be dark it can't be so having that
people are like you know overcome with
you know sadness watching it I didn't
want to depress people watching it you
know I wanted to make people feel but so
she's right for that reason as well
because there's this kind of soulfulness
but she still kind of has a light touch
you know yeah and that's what I was
afraid when I first was going to watch
it that I would be but I didn't feel it
throughout most of it I felt fairly like
it was it was like a mystery and yeah
there are parts that are you know it's
especially to the interaction between
the two of the women in the film and I'm
curious how did you cast Pam yeah I mean
like I said that Pam did enter my mind
when I was when I was writing it but I
kind of said no that's that's not gonna
happen that's impossible but we had a I
mean first of all she had done this
interview on like The Ellen DeGeneres
Show she came out and she hadn't been
interviewed for a while he hadn't done
something stuff for a while she came out
she had cut all her hair off like she's
really short and gamine and like she
looked like she was a Godard girl like
she just looked like she was not at all
like the kind of persona that you would
see seen and when she was talking on
that film on that show um you know she
she was very funny and very like
self-deprecating and she was self-aware
and I thought like the person who needs
to play signa has to be like very
self-aware of that persona so I started
kind of like the wheels were turning and
then the casting director that we had
had been casting a Verner Herzog film
that she was supposed to be in which
again like you wouldn't think Verner
Herzog and Talia Anderson but apparently
was like very close to happening and
then I just like things do fell apart
and she was looking for a script and
they sent it to her and again she called
she called me from Malibu I got this
like phone call was like in Toronto in
my bedroom and I just call from it was
Pam we talked for an hour and a half she
was so easy to talk to she really
understood the character she really
understood you know what I was trying to
do with the relationship between those
two women and how they're kind of their
versions of the same character in a way
like in a way I feel like sweetie you
could have gone on in her life had she
stayed with Jamie to be a signais in a
way because in my mind like I have a
backstory for Sweet Pea although it's
not really kind of talked about in the
film as much but to me I just felt like
there was like this connection that
those two women had because they
recognized themselves in each other even
though they were enemies she got that
right away she knows so much about art
she knows so much about film you know so
you can talk to somebody you can talk
about references we had some like
amazing conversations about Fellini
women and and all you know all these
things and and she's she's really the
coolest she's like absolutely the
coolest yeah yeah reminds me of just
kind of like the Marilyn Monroe
stereotype but then when you would read
things that she would say you know it
just it just shows that that was the one
image that was presented but it didn't
mean that that was the full package and
definitions yeah and I think she really
actually uses like Marilyn Monroe as
like kind of like I know she really you
know respects her and respects that that
you know career that Marilyn you know
had and the fact that there was it was
almost like acting like that persona is
very much a persona and Pam is very
aware of of that and she can play with
that go in and out of it it's very
fascinating
you